welcome back everyone to the beginner to
Master speedrun episode number 21
currently on a 70 game win streak and
coming into today rated
1158 so we'll try and keep it going uh
let's hop into the T pool and first
opponent playing bad username
96 starting as usual E4 we have a
scandavian
uh Queen takes D5 is a little bit more
common but Knight F6 of course is an
alternative move preparing to take the
pawn with the Knight so in this position
there are a few ways white can continue
uh Knight C3 is typical Pawn D4 is
typical Knight F3 uh I'm going to play a
move here which is probably the most
challenging move against this line which
is Bishop to
B5 uh just trying to make it so if black
wants to block with a pawn then I'll
take and I'll be up a pawn and when
Black Blocks with with the bishop I can
then move back and I provoke the bishop
to obstruct the queen from attacking the
pawn so uh yeah it's already questioned
how black wants to deal with this now we
see yeah black offering the trade uh so
I'm happy to take going up a pawn now
black is getting a bit more
development like black already has three
minor pieces developed I just have the
bishop developed
but I think I'll be happy to continue
here Bishop G4 played very quickly so
pinning the
knight uh I'm very tempted to play
Knight E5 and say oh no my queen if
black takes it it would be Checkmate uh
the problem with this move is black can
just take with a knight and it's really
oh no my knight and then The Bishop's
defended and my Bishop's attacked so uh
this would just be hope chess it's a bad
move hoping that black would go
wrong so yeah I think from
here probably find just a castle get the
king
safe it would be nice if we see this
move Knight E5 cuz then then I can take
and say oh no my queen and then checkmat
okay uh that was a funny finish or funny
funny finish and funny start to uh
episode
um episode's not finishing here though
I'll definitely play at least another
game but uh we see a very typical type
of mating pattern from the opening which
I've had many times before in uh similar
types of positions Knight E5 is is
definitely a blunder here because yeah
I'm threatening mate and also attacking
the bishop and black doesn't have time
to take the queen so black probably
should have played a move like Pawn E5
just accelerate development fight for
space prepare this or maybe later Knight
D4 uh going back I will say that I've
played this position from the black side
and I think the the two main moves here
are either Bishop to G4 to attack the
queen and also unleash and attack the
pawn or the move B5 which is kind of
interesting to attack the bishop and
then go for A5 and uh yeah play can
continue from here so nice quick one to
start the episode let's keep it going
playing anggry
Mouse from Poland and we see Pawn G3
which I think has a few names chess.com
is calling this a king's fiend K opening
I'm going to play D5 I think this is
also called the Hungarian if I'm not
mistaken Pawn E3 okay so this could also
turn into a hippo if light goes for the
double faneto with E3 and D3
uh I think I'll be happy to just control
the
center playing Pawn E5 yeah it does seem
like white is going for
hippo so we'll keep uh keep developing
Knight to
C6 I think I encountered the hippo at
least once before in the speedrun series
and White's just focusing on moving all
the pawns and not developing the minor
pieces so what do I want to do
to like try and disturb White's setup I
could just go
for like nice Central Development get
the minor pieces into the
center but there are other ways
to maybe play aggressively from early
on and I'm going to delay moving the
Knight because there might be cases
where I'll want to push the F Pawn
sooner I'm going to start with the move
Bishop to E6
uh now this prepares Queen to D7 and
like later in the the Early Middle game
if white employees the fan K and castles
then I have the Queen Bishop battery
which could be used to attack Bishop H3
sometimes will happen
later uh but White's just doing their
own thing Pawn
B3 uh I'll develop my Bishop Bishop to
D6 I'm holding back the Knight cuz I
might want to play Knight to
E7 um rather than Knight
F6 just so I'm not blocking the F
Pawn okay we finally see the first minor
piece developed for white uh on move
six so I don't want to overthink things
too much um I'm going to play the move
Queen to
D7 I pretty sure my queen is is going to
be happy
here going into the middle game and yeah
I'm going to develop the Knight to E7
now I'm staying flexible which side I'll
Castle I probably don't want to commit
the king to either side there's an idea
here which um sometimes you'll see when
when one player goes for this kingside
fan C uh one of the ways to try and
crack the setup is to go for the pawn
break and the two potential Pawn breaks
on the king's side are either F5 and F4
or H5 and
H4 and because my Rook is still on
h8 I think I'll be happy going for H5
just preparing H4 white very quickly
responds with H3 which does have the
benefit of if I play H4 then white can
play G4 and maybe try and close things
down uh but I think I'll still go for
this CU if white plays
G4 then I'll play Pawn F5
and I guess I should clarify too that
when I say Pawn break it's really just
referring to a move where I move a pawn
to attack an opponent's pawn and these
sort of moves can be very useful like
early on in the game to open the files
or just open up more lines for the
pieces so here I'm very happy to open
the H file for The Rook because now I
have The Rook the bishop and the queen
all aimed against this Pawn now the
question is can I get away with winning
the pawn CU if I take on
H3 then and the bishop supported but my
Bishop is also
pinned to The
Rook so I'm really just trying to
visualize if I take on H3 does White
have any way
to attack the bishop on the next
move I don't think
so
then they'll be ready to Castle defend
the Rook with this
rook and then the bishop will no longer
be
pinned so I think this is a a free
Pawn hoping I'm not missing anything I
don't think I
am of course if takes I'm happy to
trade and it doesn't look like White's
going to be casting King's ey in this
game King side's already crumbling a
little
bit
yeah there is uh the move Knight H5
which is actually kind of confusing
because it would leave the bishop
hanging but then allow for Knight takes
G7 attacking the king and discover
attacking The
Rook
so yeah I'm not sure what I would have
done against that move I'll have to
check after the game uh Queen E2 is very
logical White's preparing to Castle
Queen side also maybe threatening Queen
F1 to
exert more pressure against this
bishop so here I'm in time to
Castle um yeah connecting the
Rooks and now now I'm ready to move the
bishop back either to E6 maybe to G4 as
well and offer The Rook trade on H file
also maybe attack the
queen so pretty good start to the game I
mean I tried to follow principles
developed control the center uh also
yeah play the wrest on the king side won
the
pawn uh this is kind of a strange move
Bishop F1 I guess the intent is to
defend the bishop but not necessarily
trading off the bishop and this gives me
a choice like I could take on F1 I could
drop back to
G4 I think I'd
rather not trade like even though I'm up
a pawn usually when you're on material
it's uh a good idea to simplify and this
bishop
I think just has more potential than
this bishop so let's keep it on the
board and now I am offering The Rook
trade but also attacking the
queen and this Rook is defended by the
Knight
so mean if I take on H1 we'll probably
see Knight
takes yeah let's go for this Knight is
now forced to the
corner and now what to do with the
bishop I could stay in the center drop
back to E6 or I could stay aligned with
the queen draw back to
H5 I think both moves are are very fine
if I drop back to H5 the Knight can
redevelop and attack the bishop so I'm
going to stay in the
center and that way I keep the H file
unobstructed cuz Rook h8 might be
coming uh yeah I'll play Rook h8 pretty
quickly only open B on the board
attacking the
Knight and now from here there are some
options uh this move comes to mind which
attacks a knight which is not
defended and honestly this move
looks pretty nice even though it does
allow the bishop to have scope against
[Music]
G7 it'll open up the center a bit more
and because my pieces are all like
pretty centralized if the Center opens
up and there's Pawn trades it should
favor Black in some
way uh now with
F4 uh this actually allows some tactic
with Bishop to
G4 Queen supports the bishop and the
bishop skewes the queen and
Rook so it looks like I'll be winning a
bit of material and assuming the queen
moves I'll take and then I'll have a
rook and pawn for a bishop
and earlier like if if white did throw
in this move I was going to say that uh
yeah even now if white throws in this
move then I have the move Rook G8
counterattacking the
bishop um and white isn't really getting
time to capture this back for
free cuz then I'll take the bishop and
then I'll be up a whole
Rook so yeah not the best timing on
White's part to take the pawn and of
course if the bishop saves itself then
I'll save my Bishop so white just
resigns yeah it was going to be up a
full Rook going
forward um but pretty smooth game uh
hopefully this demonstrates at least one
way to play against such an opening for
white and this opening does have an
ultra solid
reputation uh like if white can just
complete development and castle
sometimes it can be a hard position to
crack but the setup that I employed with
just developing reinforcing the center
pawns and then going for this flank Pawn
push I think is one of the most
effective uh approaches against a hippo
so hopefully some lessons to take away
uh we can move on to another game
although actually before I move on I do
want to address this one
moment oh
wow wow so this was actually a mistake
on my
part I was saying earlier that if my
opponent played Knight
H5 I wasn't entirely sure what I was
going to do Knight H5 is actually a
really really good move for white like
even though it leaves a bishop
undefended like somehow the tactics
would have worked out and I would have
been in a lot of trouble as if I take
the bishop white can then take on F6 we
can see the evalar or sorry not take on
um yeah I'm reading the engine line but
white has Knight
F6 uh which is even
stronger forking the king and queen
forcing me to take back and then after
takes I'm just losing a boatload of
material I have to block with a knight
and then takes and then I guess there's
Bishop f8 but then there's Rook takes G2
and white would be up a rook in this
position
so yeah I I could have been in trouble I
mean Knight H5 it's a hard move to find
at this rating level but it's actually a
nice kind of tactical puzzle to employ
some obstruction also to employ the
discovery uh once my Bishop
moves um engine is saying the best move
would have been for me to take but then
I'm still down material the queen will
take and after takes there's Queen h8
again forcing the Knight to move
here um it's a long tactical sequence
but uh yeah Whit in in full control here
up the exchange has a battery uh I can
castle of course the game would still go
on but would not have been Pleasant for
black so okay definitely some lessons to
take away from that game uh let's move
on keep it
going let's see how this
goes from Canada we have a queen's Pawn
opening I'll play D D5 we have a London
opening so yeah the London and the
Queen's Gambit the two most common
openings within um Pawn D4 and against
this I'll develop
naturally starting with Knight
F6 again C4 I usually like to play E6
which is a Queen's Gambit
declined but against so London usually
what I like to do is actually play a
reverse Queen's
Gambit and I don't think people can see
this but my opponent's already offering
me a draw uh after just a couple moves
but uh yeah we're going to play on
decline the draw playing
C5 very quick check on B5 let's keep
developing now I am or I was gaming this
Pawn but yeah if white were to take it
there'd be ideas of Queen A5 E6 and
Bishop recapturing very often black can
win back the pawn without too much
trouble uh with Knight C3 this is
definitely not the most typical move in
the London also Bishop B5 is not the
most typical like usually white goes for
a setup with Pawn C3 Knight D2 and
Bishop comes to
D3 so this resembles more of a jobava
London and it's definitely playable um
and I have to figure out what to do here
I'm kind of out of my opening
preparation I'm kind of deciding whether
to develop this bishop first either to
F5 or G
G4 and then play E6 or just play E6
immediately and try and be solid I think
generally if you can you should develop
the bishop before committing to
E6 and yeah I think I'll go ahead and
play Bishop to G4
here now I am perhaps provoking white to
play F3 but then I don't mind moving
back and that that would deprive F3
Square for the knight uh but we see
Knight F3 so in this case white is kind
of walking into the pin and now I'll
play Pawn
E6 so I'm just trying to achieve a
harmonious development with my minor
pieces controlling the center with E6
I'm preparing to develop also defending
the pawn on
C5 and I would say the game is fairly
balanced here like um yeah taking is is
playable but it gives me the bishop here
take back
and we see Pawn H3 so yeah against this
move I mean I've had like very similar
positions in the past where like it's a
question do I want to take the pin
Knight do I want to retreat and maintain
the
pin uh in this case I think taking would
be a small mistake cuz then white can
happily activate the queen so I'll
maintain the pin and if white wants to
the bishop I don't mind this because now
with the pawns extended uh it's less
likely white will castle and if white
does Castle King side then King will be
a bit more
exposed uh but this is a a more kind of
energetic way for white to play cuz yeah
White's grabbing space on the king side
attacking my undefended Pawn attacking
the
bishop so probably want to look to
theend the pawn
here um something like Queen
B6 looks like an
option a rook C8
also guess I have to ask myself if Queen
B6 there is this move Knight A4 but then
I have some
checks should be okay let's play Queen
B6 multi-purpose move defending exerting
pressure on D4 also attacking the B2
pawn and yeah very often in this sort of
reverse Queen Gambit setup the queen
does find its way to
B6 and I was going to say earlier that
sometimes against the London opening uh
the B2 Pawn is one of the main targets
for white um that black can try and
attack early on so we do see Knight A4
now if I play this or this I'm not
actually winning any material because
white has to move C3 to block the check
and defend the Knight with the queen and
the Knight also defends
B2 so I think it makes more sense to
play Queen A5 because if I play Queen B4
or C3 then my queen would have to move
again with Queen
A5 I'm ensuring that C3 won't attack the
queen and White's going to have to play
C3 or Knight C3 to save the
Knight I guess if white plays C3 then I
have to address the fact that this Pawn
is still attacked or even with this I I
have to address the fact that the Pawn's
attacked I don't want to move back and
repeat the
position so I think I'm best off playing
Rook to C8
here just giving The Rook job in the
position the queen is nicely placed
pinning the
Knight and perhaps next move I can look
to play something like Knight E4 and
attack the pin
Knights
oh White Castles King side that's
interesting so White's uh immediately
relieving the pin so this move has less
Venom to
it and even though White's extended on
the king side it's kind of hard to
attack like there's a move
H5 um going back to the concept of Pawn
breaks to try and open up the H file but
H5 would walk into this move and then
yeah my structure would get really ugly
on the king side so I don't think I want
to do that right
away the move like Bishop D6 I don't
think works because after takes my
Bishop's not defended my Rook would be
attacked as
well so question what to do could play
Bishop
E7 I could take on
D4 probably want to move a bit more
quickly
here um I think Bishop Bishop e 7 looks
fine I'm not sure if I actually want a
castle
but um it's just a basic improving move
kind of putting the ball back in White's
quartz at some point maybe I want to
take on D4 and then perhaps play C5
again there's definitely some benefit to
having the Double C
pawns like double pawns don't have the
best reputation in chess like generally
they are considered weak because they
can't defend each other but when the
pawns are closer to the center then um
sometimes there there is some benefit H4
just going straight for the trapping of
my
Bishop this is actually a very typical
idea in jobava London which maybe I
should have been a bit more aware
of cuz if I allow this bishop E4 F3
traps the bishop I I might have to play
H5 or H6
here which is not what I want to
play but honestly like I don't see any
other way to save my
Bishop H4 is a great
move if I
take I have to watch my time
too I'm going to play
H5 like I'm getting in some time trouble
I'm also like in trouble in the position
too
so have to um have to just stay really
focused
here White's playing a nice game so far
I'm allowing this and then this I mean
this structure even though it looks ugly
like speaking of double pawns uh these
are not going to be the best double
pawns E6 could be a weakness the F pawn
moves
away but uh it's not the end of the
world now if I end up with those
pawns and let's say white will play G5
[Music]
then I'll I'll hopefully be able to cope
like I can play Knight to
D7 and one plan might be to Castle and
put the King on H7 and then be because
the structure is so closed and there's
really no no Pawn break for
white um although white is going for
Pawn break with E4
here um but there's no way for white to
easily like open up the structure on the
king side so I think I will be happy to
Castle
here getting the king to a safe place
also using the f file which has just
been
opened um of course there were other
moves I could have considered there like
taking either Pawn but I'm leaving the
tension attacking the undefended
bishop and E4 is definitely I mean it's
attempting to just blow up in the center
very confrontational move uh the
drawback with this move is that this
Pawn is less
supported and I mean I think it's very
likely I'll take next move and then if
the queen has to take back then I can
look for ways to attack the queen
something like E5 or C5 or Bishop
C5 it will depend what white does here
though Bishop D2 very tricky move so if
I take on
D4 white can then take on D5 unleashing
the bishop to attack my
queen okay let's be careful I think I'll
move back to
C7 um Safety First did not want to walk
into any discoveries
there we see the trade so if I take here
there's takes
here probably better off taking so I'm
UND doubling the
cwns
queen2 attacking
that so if I take and then take and then
King
H7 D5 could
I I have to
defend Queen B no Queen B6 Knight
A4 and then Queen
C6 let's try
this definitely feeling the pressure
here White's found some nice
counterattacking
moves and down to two and a half minutes
Knight takes D5
which I've actually overlooked this this
does win
material but I have Rook
F7 maybe I'll win back
material yeah the Queen's attacked I
defend the Knight through x-ray vision
and I still have this battery is white
going to take on
C5 with the
Counterattack and maybe I can take with
Knight
things are definitely getting
spicy yeah let's take on
D4 now I still have this idea like tuing
the king
away okay we see
B3 I could take on can I take on
C2 allowing Queen E8 and then Knight
f8 I really have to watch my
time I'm going to play this move
first wasn't sure if I if taking on C2
is the safest allowing the queen to come
in okay so white
defends I'm playing this move to try and
set up Knight E5 and then eventually KN
have
three
um with Time Low I'm I'm uh trying to
rely more on intuition
now with F4 this does give the E4 square
like especially because the pawn can't
move
backwards so there's some idea to get
the knight in although I have to watch
out for Bishop
B4 yeah I probably don't want to allow
Bishop
B4 I stop
it or maybe I do allow
it CU Bishop B4 I can take on
F4 looks like the bishop is tied down
the Knight should be making its way to
E4 um so yeah white abandoned the F Pawn
there is this really scary pin but it's
also scary for white cuz Rook G4 is a
threat the king is getting a little bit
more
exposed and it's the question can white
like somehow exploit the Knight without
leaving the king
neglected Rook
G4 Rook G4 is hard to
stop Queen
H2 yeah let's go ahead and
check I could
take I don't really want to trade Queens
though I'm going to play this
move this is threatening Maiden
two I'm keeping the Knight
defended but if okay of course if takes
I I Checkmate in a couple
moves yeah trading Queens it would have
simplified light's
defending move in like
this completely abandoning the Knight
falling below a minute here is by far
the toughest game of the speedrun so
far rookie
here maybe we
trade actually Rook there I have this
move this is a really nice
move does it work though think it's okay
takes I take back and then
Fork now I'm threatening
this
okay stayed alive there that's uh
had to really stay
focused white was very resourceful this
game they're probably uh very much
underrated in this
account yeah an end game like this um
like 30 something seconds it's plenty of
time just promote a pawn then go for the
lad
mate
and what a
game um I feel like I was probably in
trouble somewhere that
game um I mean my opponent offered me a
draw after after my second move after
their third move so it's I think it's
good that we fought we we had a much
more entertaining battle than uh taking
a draw after just a few
moves um maybe some of the top Grand
Masters in the world can can learn from
declining draws early on but uh yeah
let's just go through
here um I mean white played kind of a
non-conventional opening putting the
pieces on um maybe not the most
traditional
squares but was able to get away with it
and then yeah this combination of H3
g495 and then later H4
H5 actually caused me some big problems
and
here yeah I I basically had to move my H
Pawn at some point I could have thrown
in takes I started with this allowing
the
trade and white is slightly for Choice
here but and it's a very imbalanced
position actually very rich position now
E4 was yeah probably not the best move
but it made the position uh very
complicated
and yeah Bishop
D2 engine really doesn't like I was
scared when I saw this move though um so
I had to be super careful with the
queen takes takes Queen
E2 but actually everything was under
control and was able
to solidify and this was actually a nice
uh construction I do want to give a
shout out to Anish giri I remember
watching one of his older lectures I
don't know if it's on YouTube or maybe
another platform but he was talking
about how in like a similar but
different sort of opening that sometimes
the structure is actually like really
beneficial even with having the double G
pawns it creates a really nice uh safe
space for the king and we definitely saw
that in this game with White's King
being a lot more
exposed
and yeah look like um like white fought
really well put up resistance this
Knight E4 move was a nice touch to save
the Knight and essentially lead to the
simplification so uh good game to my
opponent um I think that will do it for
this episode uh thanks everyone for
watching if you have questions leave
them Below had a nice mix of games today
and do stay tuned for more if you like
the content subscribe and I'll see see
you guys soon